garding motivation and today i will
speak in german
i make a lot of videos here on the
subject of learning languages why because i rea
ly like learning languages and i believe t
at all four people all people can
o it they have the ability to
earn languages and the most important th
ng  is motivation and there
are three important questions
first can i do
that i.e. can i learn a foreign
language can i reach a person
fluency or fluently
in a foreign language you have to
believe that
i know that if you have never done
it then it is difficult
so to have enough confidence so to
believe that you can
achieve that goal so before i
learned french to a pretty high
level that i have i have so before
i had that experience then
so then i didn't have
that confidence
and that's why i fell  and after i i
have french then i have him
eh japanese spani  learned sch and many
other languages but this trust
what is important to her and if she or yo
have never done that then
ou have to believe that because i am
onvinced we all have this abili
y you h
ve to say yes i can do that if these
if  you think you
can't do that
then it's better not to continue
if for example you have guests on a
trip and you think you won't get to the end
point then it's better not to go on
that trip
first of all the question can i do
that  the answer is yes it can
be i will answer your second question
does it work i.e. the method
used is it effective or is
it the most effective method
i think so my main method i.e.
much higher the very much
read and  the focus on
understanding also vocabulary so waiting
to add
for me is the most effective
most effective method and but if you
think one or the other people have
a  Different attitudes sir others so ideas
so mainly do you have
to keep at it you have to sign and you
have to believe if you believe then dede
effectively effective hayek or don't know
your method then the iss works
so second question works what you
do must believe yes it works
and third  It's worth asking because it
can't be that easy to learn a language. It
can be a lot of fun. It can be
interesting, but it's also a
bit difficult because when you start
, you have to read and hear a lot of uninteresting
content and a lot of it is new
learn and forget words
now learn again forget again and
de
even if you start with more
interesting so authentically
you remembered to last practiced so
learn and
study there are always so many new ones
so which cable to the Neuerburg and that
is a lot of work  when you
start to speak then you may like a
lot of mistakes and now ic  h i
always do very well would be if i
speak german but but it is worth it because there
is so much to know people from
other cultures so to different
countries so to travel and deal with these people
and and read through all of them
is not reading or cs  can you
invite broadcast so i have for
example i wanted to practice a bit of
german today and then i
found a building by thomas
mann wanted by joseph from austria
he talks about effective management that is
present as a very interesting
podcast podcast about history so can
you learn a lot of things not only
the dd the language that's how it is for
me but everyone has to decide for themselves
if you think if you think it's
not worth it then i don't think you will
be successful that's why I
can ask three more questions  i doing this
works its worth if these
three days you can say yes then you will have
enough motivation to reach your goal
oak
and so can speak fluently in another language
thanks see you bye